>> Kat: THE U.S. AIR FORCE
ACADEMY HAS GONE WOKE.
ONE OF ITS DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION TRAINING PRESENTATIONS
INSTRUCTS CADETS TO USE
GENDER-NEUTRAL LANGUAGE.
SO, "MOM AND DAD" ARE OUT, AND
"CAREGIVER OR PARENT" ARE IN.
THE GUIDANCE ALSO ASKS THEM TO
SUBSTITUTE "Y'ALL OR FOLKS" FOR
"YOU GUYS," AND "PARTNER" FOR
BOYFRIEND OR GIRLFRIEND.
STRAIGHT MEN NEED NOT APPLY!
THE APPLICATION SAYS, "IF YOU'RE
A CISGENDER WOMAN, A TRANSGENDER
WOMAN, NONDAIRY, AGENDER,
BIGENDER, ANOTHER FORM OF
MINORITY, THIS IS FOR YOU.
IF YOU'RE A CISGENDER MAN, THIS
PROGRAM IS NOT FOR YOU
"
I COULDN'T IMAGINE WHAT COULD BE
MORE DESTRUCTIVE TOMORROW THAN
THIS DIVISIVE AND PARSING
LANGUAGE.
>> Guy: INCLUDING GAY MEN,
PARTLY.
WE ARE OUT OF THIS PROGRAM!
I UNDERSTAND THERE ARE AFFINITY
PROGRAMS.
WHAT GETS ME MORE IS "MOM AND
DAD."
REALLY?
WE CAN'T SAY THAT AT THE
AIR FORCE ACADEMY?
"CAREGIVERS?"
NO ONE TALKS LIKE THIS.
BOYFRIEND/GIRLFRIEND, IT'S FINE.
LET PEOPLE JUST USE WORDS THAT
THEY'VE USED FOR ALL OF TIME.
IT'S NOT OFFENSIVE.
WE CAN BE INCLUSIVE AND
EMPATHETIC TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
DIFFERENT WITHOUT REWRITING OUR
ENTIRE LANGUAGE IN THE WAY THAT
WE SPEAK.
FOR THE MILITARY TO BE INVOLVED
IN THIS, TALK ABOUT A
DISTRACTION FROM THE ACTUAL
MISSION.
THIS WOULD BE, I THINK, A
GLARING EXAMPLE.
>> Kat: NEXT TIME AT A FAMILY
GIVING I WILL SAY "CAREGIVER" MY
DAD OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND SEE
HOW LONG IT TAKES HIM TO ASK ME
IF I NEED TO GO TO THE HOSPITAL.
>> Emily: TO YOUR POINT, I
LIVE AT THE ACADEMY RESPONDED.
THEIR SPOKESPERSON SAID IT'S FOR
WAR FIGHTING EFFECTIVENESS.
>> Guy: NO, IT'S NOT.
>> Kat: I'M NOT AN EXPERT IN
BATTLE, I CAN ADMIT THAT, BUT I
WANT TO ASK THEM HOW SO.
CAN ANYBODY FOLLOW UP AND SAY,
"WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
IF YOU CAN CALL --
IT'S BETWEEN YOU AND YOUR
PARENTS WHAT YOU WANT TO CALL
THEM.
>> Guy: CAREGIVERS.
>> Kat: HE'S MY DAD!
AND SOMETIMES I CALL HIM CHIEF,
WHICH I THINK THEY'D ALSO HAVE
ANOTHER PROBLEM WITH.
>> Emily: I LOVE THAT, CHIEF
TIMPF.
I WOULD BE OUT BECAUSE I SAY
"YOU GUYS" EVERY FIVE SECONDS.
I'D BE REJECTED AND EXPELLED BY
THE SECOND DAY.
I COULD NEVER BE A SOLDIER.
>> Dr. Nesheiwat: I SAY
"Y'ALL" ANYWAY.
WHEN WE WASTE TIME ON THIS SORT
OF NONSENSE, YOU TAKE AWAY TIME
TO PREPARE FOR WAR.
YOU TAKE AWAY TIME TO BE
PREPARED AGAINST CHINA AND IRAN
AND NORTH KOREA AND RUSSIA.
WHAT ELSE?
WE ALREADY HAVE A SHORTAGE OF
MILITARY RECRUITS RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS GOING TO FURTHER DETER
THEM AND MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY SEE WHAT'S
GOING ON IN AFGHANISTAN, HOW WE
WITHDREW, AND THEN WE HAVE THE
ISSUES OF NOT BEING HEALTHY
ENOUGH, NOT MAKING THE WEIGHT
RESTRICTIONS, BEING ABLE TO
COMPLETE THE PT TESTS.
YOU TAKE THIS IN A
CONSIDERATION, IT WILL TOTALLY
DETER THEM FROM JOINING, AND
THAT COULD BE A NATIONAL
SECURITY RISK IF YOU HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF SERVICEMEN AND
WOMEN.
I JUST THINK WE NEED TO REALLY
STAY FOCUSED ON WHAT REALLY
MATTERS, AND THAT'S BEING STRONG
ENOUGH TO FIGHT THESE WARS AND
BEING ABLE TO PROTECT AMERICANS.
>> Emily: THAT'S WHAT I WOULD
CALL MACRO AGGRESSIONS, BUT THEY
ARE WORRIED ABOUT MACRO
MICRO-AGGRESSIONS OF BEING
CALLED PARENT OR DAD, I CAN'T
KEEP IT STRAIGHT.
>> Kayleigh: THERE IS A
NEW YORK MANHATTAN PRIVATE
SCHOOL THAT "THE NEW YORK POST"
WROTE ABOUT THAT IS ALSO GETTING
RID OF MOMS AND DADS.
THE EXPECTABLE TERMS ARE
"GROWN-UPS, FOLKS, FAMILIES,
GUARDIANS."
IF YOU KID SAYS, "HEY, FOLKS!"
THAT'S WHERE THEY'RE GETTING IT.
ESPECIALLY IN THE CONTEXT OF
WAR, I REMEMBER THE SCENE FROM
"LETTERS FROM IWO JIMA," WHERE A
JAPANESE SOLDIER IS DYING AND ON
THE DEATHBED THEY READ A LETTER
FROM HIS MOM.
THE AMERICAN SOLDIER GETS
TEARY-EYED AND THIS MOMENT,
DESPITE BEING ON OPPOSITE SIDES
OF THE BATTLEFIELD, SOMETHING
UNITING THE SOLDIERS.
THAT UNITING CONCEPT WAS "MOM,"
FAMILY.
NOW WE HAVE TO MOVE TO "FOLKS"
AND "GUARDIANS."
IT MAKES NO SENSE.
>> Emily: ALL I CARE ABOUT IS
WHETHER YOU ARE FLYING THAT
FIGHTER PLANE EFFECTIVELY,
WHETHER YOU ARE PERFORMING THE
DUTIES OF A SOLDIER, RATHER THAN
WHAT YOU ARE CALLING YOUR
PARENTS.
CAN I SAY PARENTS?
>> Guy: YOU CAN SAY PARENTS.
MOM AND DAD IS AT.
>> Emily: WILL THEY HAVE IT
TAPED UP IN THE COCKPIT?
THIS IS RIDICULOUS!
IT'S ASININE.
OUR TAX DOLLARS ARE PAYING FOR
THIS.
>> Guy: CAN I JUST SAY, AND
PERFECT COMFORTABLE WITH YOU
GUYS SAYING "YOU GUYS" ALL THE
TIME?
LET THE RECORD REFLECT, THERE IS